- Hi Chace Crawford, how are you?
- I'm good, Drew.
Thank you for having me this morning.
- Thank you for coming on the show.
I was watching your
interview with Jimmy Fallon
and I was so excited
to talk about football
at Chippendales and all that.
I was like, well, they're
talking about all of it on there.
- I had a whole other career plan.
Yeah, B plan, it was great, so.
- Yeah, all of the stories I
wanted to talk to you about,
I was like, oh they, that
one, yep that one, yeah, okay.
So I, we did a little research
and we found out that there are fan
pages about your eyebrows.
- Really?
Wow, better than my feet, I guess.
But my, you know, that's good.
My eyebrows are up there.
- How are your feet?
Are they, are they
groomed semi 'cause guys
never clip their toe nails.
What's up with that?
- No, not at all, barely.
- Get, this is men.
I want to buy all of you a, a clipper
but how do you feel about
the fact that there's
fan pages with your eyebrows?
- That's weird.
And I got, I don't know.
I guess, well, I guess
the big eyebrows are in,
you know, I don't know.
Do you Chace Crawford?
- I grew up in the era of Brooke Shields
and the big eyebrows were everything.
This, I did not see you do anywhere.
Would you possibly indulge
doing an eyebrow dance with me?
- An eyebrow, yes.
I mean, how's that, how's that work?
We just.
- I've never done it before
but I feel like I want
to start a movement.
Okay, so this is hashtag eyebrow dance
and we're kicking it off
with none other than M.
Eyebrows, Mr. Everything,
Chace Crawford, all right
So I said,
let's pick three different types of music
and we're gonna kick it off with jazz.
I've never done this either, so.
- Perfect.
(light jazz music)
(laughs)
Hit them, okay the next cue.
Oh.
(bright, funky music)
The next cue, oh, okay.
(light pop music)
Okay thank you, thank you, thank you.
I, I have no idea how that felt for you
or that was kind of weird
but it was really fun and
you're just fun and playful.
By the way.
I know you're like, suit is
getting a lot of attention too
on "The Boys," mm hmm.
- Oh, it's got a little bit of attention.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a, it's tight, you know,
it's like a big wet suit onesie.
Yeah, there it is.
The gloves too, with the
web fingers, you know,
it's a, it's a nice touch.
- I think your role,
all sort of, you know,
"Gentlemen" and "Gossip Girl"
and everything aside and
eyebrow fan pages and hot wetsuits.
You're playing a really interesting
character in "The Boys,"
and I just think the whole
tone of it is so interesting.
I'm a tone freak.
And I thought "The Boys,"
had such an interesting tone
and I know your character
deals with a lot of taboos
and it's really exciting
to watch you attack this.
- Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I know first season,
we're kind of like,
I'm like, is this tonally
gonna work, like, you know,
going from a pretty darkly,
darkly comedic scene to me,
you know, getting a,
breaking a dolphin out
of ocean land or whatever
but those tonal shifts
worked and it's a lot of fun.
It's a lot of fun for me to
do something totally different
and you know, kind of play this
dark interesting, you know,
defective character, so.
- Well, I think this a little interview
we've done has a lot of
weird tones in it too
and I hope that's okay for you.
'Cause I really had fun and by the way,
I love the Cowboys and I
know your brother in law is a
Cowboy, Tony Romo.
And I mean, that just must be so much fun.
Go Dallas.
- I know Go Dallas.
- You grew up there.
Or you grew up in Lubbock.
- I was born in Lubbock.
I grew up there for like a
couple years then in Dallas,
mainly my whole life.
So yeah, I've been out there.
My family's still there.
I've got three little nephews and yeah.
- Well, I have to say,
I think I'm a sky lover.
I'm in, I'm a California
hippie, big surprise.
I love the sky and there is
no other skies in the world
on planet earth like in Texas.
- No other skies, good thunderstorms.
It's nice down there.
- Thank you Chace for gracing
us with your presence.
You are so awesome, so playful.
"The Boys" is available on Amazon Prime.
(light music)